السفير سوليفان ، أريد فقط أن أبدأ
معك ، لقد سمعت أن تقرير ريبلي سيقدم
، والآن نتعلم أن بوتين
لن يعقد مؤتمره الصحفي في نهاية العام ،
وهو أمر يقوم به سنويًا ،
كما أنه تلقى أسئلة من
الشعب الروسي خلال ذلك.  هذه
هي المرة الأولى منذ عام 2013 التي
لن يفعل فيها ذلك منذ ما يقرب من
10 سنوات أه تعلم أننا ننظر فقط
إلى عدد قليل منها على الشاشة هنا
إنه تقليد سنوي وهو سفير ما
هو المغزى  من تخطي بوتين
هذا العام ،
شكرًا جيدًا لآرون ، إنه لأمر جيد جدًا أن أكون
معك ، أعتقد أنها علامة على القلق
بشأن دعمه المحلي ، فهو
يفضل إخراج فيكتور بوت وجعله
يقرأ النص الذي شاهدناه للتو.
له أه يتحدث إذا كنت
تعتقد أن هذه الكلمات كانت كلماته في
الأصل ، فأنت مخطئ للأسف ،
وهذا مثل حديث الكرملين من
خلال بوث ، فهو مفيد لهم باعتباره
لسان حال بوتين لا يريد الخروج
وقضاء ساعات قبل الصحفيين حتى
القديس.  أكل الإعلام أه
وخاطر بطرح الأسئلة الصعبة والمحرجة